-Welcome. Thank you.
-That is about an amazing band
that makes you want to dance.
-That's exactly right.
-Shout out to the band.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Welcome to the show.
You've recently been named
E's red carpet host.
-Yes.
-This is -- this is a big deal.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Yes.
-This is a big deal.
-We -- it's such an honor and
I'm having such a good time.
we just did the People's Choice
Awards a few months ago
and on Sunday, we're doing
the Screen Actors Guild Awards,
the S.A.G. Awards.
And I love artists.
I love actors. The S.A.G.
Awards are always so much fun,
and it is star-studded.
When I got the list of
the people I'm potentially
interviewing, I was like --
[ Gasps ]
I really had a gasp,
but I was like,
"I need to really get it
together."
Because they're names like --
-Who are you excited about?
-People like Leonardo DiCaprio.
-Uh-huh.
-Like, if you're an actor,
and Leonardo DiCaprio is,
like, [emphatically] an actor.
-Yeah.
-Denzel Washington is
[emphatically] an actor.
-Yeah, he's unbelievable.
Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
-Cate Blanchett --
"Cate the Great."
-No. "Cate the Great,"
she's unbelievable.
-It's fun, though,
because it's two hours.
I realized the day of,
I was like,
"I can't go to the bathroom.
I can't leave."
I have to be on the red carpet
for two hours.
So I stopped all liquids
at 2:00 P.M.
-That's smart.
-Because the red carpet starts
at 6:00.
-Very smart.
-And you're there
the whole time,
and there's all this stuff
coming at you, but you have to
be on your toes and be on --
think on your feet.
And anything can happen,
and that's actually really fun
and exciting.
-You've had a bunch of jobs,
but this one I read about
and it made me laugh because
I go,
"I don't know if
I remember this."
But I remember the show,
kind of.
Was it like, "I Will Work for
Diddy," or something?
Or --
-"I Want to Work for Diddy."
I was on -- in 2008,
I did a reality show
called "I Want to Work for
Diddy."
-I remember the show.
-It was my phase of saying "yes"
to everything.
-Yeah.
-[ Laughs ]
-Did you want to work for Diddy?
-No, girl.
[ Laughter ]
No. It was an --
[ Cymbal crashes ]
[ Laughter and applause ]
-That's it. I don't know.
I can't take that.
-It was an -- it was an
opportunity to be on television.
This was 2008, so, like,
a transperson had never been
on a competition reality show
in 2008.
-Yeah.
-It was about building
relationships with
the casting director.
I didn't really want to do it,
but they loved me.
And I think I -- because
I didn't care, I went in,
I was myself.
And the interesting of them --
there are so many interesting
things that happened
on that show, but because
I had watched "Making the Band,"
I knew that Diddy would wake you
up in the middle of the night
to do stuff, and I was like,
"I do not want to be
on national television without
my makeup
at 2:00 in the morning."
So, at night, I would wash all
my makeup off, reapply it,
and then go to sleep.
[ Laughter ]
-See? That's how you do it.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-And sure enough --
-Genius.
-The second challenge,
we were wakened at, like,
2:00 or 3:00 in the morning,
and I woke up, and I was like,
"Yes."
[ Laughter ]
-And here you are now.
-Yes.
-Here you are now. I want to
talk about "inventing Anna" too.
-Oh, my God.
- You're doing it great, though.
Everyone is crushing
on the show.
It's -- congrats,
number one show on Netflix.
-Thank you. Thank you.
-Not too bad.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Number one show on Netflix.
But your character is based on
a real person.
-Yes. I play --
so "Inventing Anna" is about
this woman named Anna Delvey,
AKA Anna Sorokin,
who is a fake heiress who conned
the New York social scene
several years ago.
It's based on a true story.
And I play a woman named
Kacy Duke, who was her
personal trainer
and she's a life coach.
And I got to meet Kacy.
She trained me.
I had a four hour lunch with her
where she told me
her life story.
She lived this incredible life.
She's -- Speaking of
Denzel Washington,
she trained everyone from
Denzel Washington
to Lenny Kravitz
to Julianne Moore.
And she's been in the business
for, you know, over 30 years.
She's a legend. And she's
this really spiritual woman
who is incredible.
And she got, sort of, roped into
this crazy, crazy scheme --
-What does she think
of your performance?
-She has been so ama--
and I was so nervous.
I was, like,
really in so much anxiety.
Because I was like, "Oh, my God.
if Kacy hates it,
this is going to be terrible."
But she sent me
the sweetest message.
She sent me flowers.
She said, "Congratulations.
Laverne is killing it."
-Aww.
-She has been so sweet.
And a friend of hers tweeted me.
They said -- they were like,
"I've known Kacy Duke
for 20 years
and Laverne Cox nailed it."
And I was like, "Oh, my God."
-That's all you need.
-Yeah.
-That's all you need, right?
[ Cheers and applause ]
-It's a great show.
I want to show everyone a clip.
Here's Laverne Cox
in "Inventing Anna."
Take a look.
-She is out there by a pool
while I am here dodging
calls from my credit card
company.
-I heard if you legally change
your name,
they can't make you pay that.
But chill. She'll know.
-Easy for you to chill,
she paid you back.
And how are you so calm
right now?
-I'm just not letting Anna
take anything more from me.
No more of my time.
No more of my attention.
-I wish I had your zen.
You're not angry at all.
-Here's the thing about anger.
When you're angry,
you're just a character
in someone else's story.
But when you let your anger go,
you reclaim your own story,
become your own protagonist
again.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Laverne Cox!
Check out "Inventing Anna,"
which is streaming now
on Netflix.